good evening thank you for bearing with
us ladies and gentlemen slightly lighten
the 6:15 start
we've got tonight's planning East
Committee
I'm Andy Crump and I will be chairing
tonight's meeting so us members of
public and offices and cap system ensure
their phones are either on silent or
switched off and could members of the
public when a speaker speaking to please
refrain from interrupting the speaker
however tempting it might be it might be
me you want to interrupt but please
could you get these speaker finish like
to introduce the top table motion action
legal services in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal town
planning institutions members are not
bound by the case officers
recommendation or by any oral advice
Eddy wrench senior planning officer
Zoya's off a car planning assistant
right thank you very much we'll move on
to item number two on the agenda which
is disclosure of interests Oh any
apologies yes
and we move on to disclose of interest
any council Perry good evening chair as
the ward member for Wells borne East I
will be sitting out on the nine Kyneton
Road application thank you very much any
anybody else all right then we'll move
on to the next item on the agenda
good Thank You counsel bonds our first
application is number 18 / 2 0 1 0 9 / o
UT Compton building station works for
any Compton outline plan an application
for the construction of up to 20
dwellings or matters reserved except for
access and Eddie will be presenting this
one security Thank You chair the site is
located to the south of Station Road on
the edge of the village of Finney
Compton 10 miles at the north of Bambury
and six miles south of salvan both of
which are reached by the air a four to
three to the east the eastern boundary
is adjacent to the Chilton main railway
line beyond the railway line a network
rail service yard to the northeast is a
marina and the Oxford Canal and further
commercial development the eastern
boundary is adjacent to the Chilton main
railway line as can be seen here there's
also some surrounding agricultural uses
and the edge of the penny compton
village can be seen on their western
side of the frame here the application
site forms part of a large brownfield
site to the south of Station Road which
measures of measures approximately 5.2
Hector's overall the rest of the site
Kearney has an outline permission for 80
dwellings with the reserved masters
submission currently being assessed by
the council the site is stepped over two
levels with the southern part of the
site significantly higher and more
visibly prominent in the landscape there
are some hedgerows and planting to the
southern and western site boundaries the
site can be seen here outlined in red
with an indicative layout potentially
coming forward at reserved matters shown
on the right-hand side of the slide this
slide is from the proposed site x-axis
and shows vivid visibility splays to the
east and west this photo is from within
the site looking eastwards with the
existing telecommunication master and
the railway lam beyond the vegetation
to the very rare and finally this photo
is from the top level of the site
looking northwards with a railway line
on the right hand side and Station Road
in the centre just next to the line of
fences you can see in the center of the
site updates include a confirmation from
county highways of there no objection
subject to conditions chairman the
recommendation is to grant permission
subject to the completion of the section
106 the conditions and notes on pages 11
to 16 of the agenda and the two
additional conditions proposed by county
highways
thank you you ready our first speaker
which is Clare Lucy please this place
the red lights are come on don't get too
close to catch the bonds I think that's
[Laughter]
three minutes which like a warning and
well thank you very much for time to
address the committee my name is Kai
Lucio Aptus agent on behalf of Holmes
England and we want to also thank and
the case office of his consideration of
the application his report presents the
proposal the consultation responses and
recommends outline planning permission
is granted although I do not want to
repeat this assessment I would like to
take an opportunity to explain the role
of Holmes England and the key benefits
that will be delivered by the proposed
development in line with government
objectives Holmes England as a public
body are tasked with helping more people
access better homes in this case this
has meant along as along with the
adjoining site this has meant demolition
and remediation work to provide a clean
site ready for house builder although
the adjoining parcel has outlined
permission granted in 2014 this has not
yet been implemented Holmes England
input will ensure residential
development is delivered on a redundant
and previously developed brownfield site
the majority of rip which already has
outlined permission the past will
subject to this application sits between
the railway line and the out and the
existing outline site the application
has been submitted to enable a
comprehensive read residential scheme
alongside the joining parcel with single
shared access from Station Road and
landscaping and open space to link both
we appreciate the representations of
councillor Williams the parish council
and local residents and want to assure
you that the application of course
strategy policy and the opportunity for
alternative employment use have been
considered in detail the existing
buildings have been demolished and
potential for any alternative employment
use is significantly limited by the
residential development
on the adjoining site the site is not
allocated for employment and has been
vacant for a considerable amount of time
a market assessment with input from
commercial agents considered both office
and industrial uses and did not identify
any demand for new employment use the
site of the large rural brownfield sites
and will not result in the loss of any
Greenfield land for housing on site open
space and landscaping will significantly
improve the appearance of the redundant
industrial use and introduce additional
accessible green space for the local
community link to the adjacent
residential site the application will
contribute towards community
infrastructure through sill payment
based on the illustrative layout
approximately 250,000 pounds 30 seconds
for an affordable contribution for
affordable housing contribution is
proposed in line with policy the foreman
scale of development is appropriate to
the location and context of the site and
permitted residential adjacent the case
offices report confirms the principle of
residential is acceptable and we request
you confirm his recommendation and
approval Thank You agent Perry thank you
and good evening
obviously both the ward member and
parish council have objected to this
application can you advise the level of
engagement you've had particularly with
the parish council it's a very great
shame they're not here this evening
and the parish council were consulted at
much earlier stage when homes in homes
England first became involved in this in
this site meaning the adjacent parcel
and this in this piece of land and so
when Holmes England first purchased the
total site and they met with the parish
council and presented at parish council
meeting then at that time this scheme
included the adjacent parcel so the part
with with outline permission and an
illustrative layout that also included
this this part and at that time we were
aware that we would need to do need to
do some work on on the
parcel of the site and it would need to
be subject to a new a new outline
application since that time and more
directly in response to this application
and we have sent letter to the Parish
Council just to explain the proposal and
try to answer some of their some of
their concerns really outlining the
availability of open space and the
opportunity for landscaping and the
seochon ceiling affordable housing
contribution before I go to council
cargle somebody didn't turn up from the
parish council to speak what they hadn't
registered in time so they want to there
was somebody here just clarify my point
guys the cargo Thank You Gillian a
couple of questions about May just
picking up on the point about the
potential useful employment on the site
could you talk a little bit more and
then you said you actually looked into
that but how deep did he go where do you
have the tires except you just to go
into that for me please so in terms of
the potential for future employment use
the parish council do do stay in their
response that their previous the outline
application and did kind of leave this
parcel as it was marked on the planets
potentially suitable for employment and
the buildings that were left over from
previous use just weren't fit for any
employment purpose so the nature of them
has meant they've had to be demolished
in support of this application we and
we've undertaken an exercise with office
and industrial agents just to test the
market really so to see where where
there is demand for space usually in
kind of their commercial knowledge and
then also in the wider area where there
is availability where there is
availability was based aware existing
supply where there is existing supply
and the result of that assessment is
just in this location wouldn't be
attractive for for employment type
development
anymore and with the with the adjacent
residential development it was just
severely limit opportunity for
employment so with with such close
neighbors you obviously wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't be able to introduce
the use that might have extended
operational hours or significant
significant levels of noise that might
might have been on-site previously
chairman do I have a second question if
I may
thank you very much - um the second
question I would like to raise is a
little bit more clarification and I'm
not sure whether or not this is a
technical but I asked you first if I may
and that's to do with noise from the
train line and the mitigation that
you're going to be proposing and then
that's going forward it the reserved
matter stage I appreciate that but
things like for example I get the noise
and I get the 35 decibels etc however
it's also ventilation within the
buildings because obviously to change
the device walls which is relatively low
as has been explained to us today by the
plank manager here that in actual fact
it's it is very low valued so that would
mean closed windows how do we get
ventilation into the properties and so
what we had what we've submitted with
and I suppose without wanting to wanting
to use the reserve the reserve matters
do tell us as the answer and with the
application we've submitted a noise
assessment and that's looked at the site
and where a suitable noise level could
be achieved and one of the conditions
proposed proposed by ID and included in
this report is would just ensure that
those levels are achieved and we've
shown a noise burned along the railway
line - that's kind of the start of the
mitigation I guess and then depending on
the orientation of units once the layout
comes forward at detail stage and then
we'll be able to look at things things
like glazing and and just the
orientation of units within the site
those levels are achieved indicate yeah
just a quick question be on the the blue
this the plan that showed your your
ownership land which included that piece
to the other side of the road
is that a brownfield site
I think things are fair points the
reason behind the question because if
it's a brownfield site is it proposed to
come forward for additional houses at a
later stage no I don't think that's a
fair point no further questions right
thank you very much
as we all know that Kemp's the witness
is not pretty well I've agreed that I
will read a statement out on his behalf
I'm afraid don't what about it in the
same voice as cancer wins this I'll do
my best I cannot support the suffocation
which on first consideration is quite
straightforward and would in normal
circumstances be supported
however the devil is in the detail when
the application for the adjoining site
was submitted I supported the original
proposal since it included a small
number of employment opportunities
bucking onto the railway line it now
appears that the developers and Counting
difficulty found in tenants for such a
proposal this is a surprise since within
a few hundred meters of this side there
are numerous similar facilities that
have hardly been refurbished while newly
constructed obviously to meet local
demand its amended application is on a
brownfield site provided an additional
number of houses and together with the
orderly approve houses on the Ajani
aside or put an additional strain on the
resources of the villages so the case
officer's report states that the nearest
village co-op is 400 metres away but I
would judge is more like 600 metres
distance I'm not the other side of the
railway line are stated the whole
development will by substantial stress
on the facilities of funny Compton ie
the primary school on the dr. surgery
are both odd
subscribed it should be remembered that
the facilities are funny Compton not
only serve this village but also
surrounding communities of åland us it
north and not get farm Barret Center I
believe that this additional 20 houses
will be the straw that breaks the
camel's back how the village will cope
with the extra traffic that will be
created has not been addressed if this
application is supported by committee
I can only consider it as a missed
opportunity for the creation of
employment opportunity which would be
adjusted gesture towards the lost
employment from such a large company
bamboo buildings before my left aside I
trust that you will reject this
application and the original proposal
for employment opportunity within the
site remains thank you I won't be asking
answering any questions on that so we
can move on to points of clarification
how's the cargo thank you Karen is a few
points by may council Williams refers to
[Music]
putting extra or undue stress on the
limited services of put her in the
village in the area can you comment on
that place you want to make a note to
the use Eddie the next one is extra
traffic which is referred to as well and
finally counter Williams quite rightly
wants to see some employment in the
areas we all would like that but can I
get a reality check on whether or not we
would be able to get purely into them
independently business development on
that site in other words would the BAE a
call for it and it would it be funded
would it be a viable scheme so if you
could just outlined those for me please
in terms of services if any Compton's
obviously identified as local service
village of a quite significant skies and
think service level to so obviously i
was quite a reasonable level of services
has obviously got shops public transport
into lamington in terms of purely course
strategy numbers
it obviously has received quite a
significant number towards the figure
shown over and a large portion out that
is that eighty dwellings on the rest of
the site through the eighty dwellings on
that side plus the twenty here
there's obviously contributions towards
sill and the affordable housing and the
public open space which all goes to
increasing provision of services within
the area on balance whilst they
obviously will be a long-term need for
that money to be distributed within the
village to increase services and
potentially bus services it's not
there's no identify evidence to say that
there's any of those services are at
breaking point as it were or that
there's not a capacity within the
village to it to account for these
twenty additional dwellings so on that
basis with the additional funds coming
from the development it's fair
unbalanced that you know it would be
sustainable
given the twenty additional in purely
traffic terms obviously how highways of
assessed is based on its existing use or
previous use before it was demolished of
an employment site so there's a existing
use and trips that were originally made
on that area for that use and even if it
was to remain an employment use there's
obviously a certain amount of trips and
potentially larger hqv type movements by
on that basis so in general terms you
would potentially likely have a
a drop in the amount of overall all
trips because 20 dwellings would
obviously have less than a large
potential employment use generates in
particular times peak times and so on
that basis I would say that uses
Residential's like to have probably less
of an impact on terms of trance traffic
and it also would be utilizing the same
access to the western end of the site
that has been approved as part of the 80
dwellings so as I said again our offices
determination is that there wouldn't be
any significant impact on on this on
them on Station Road which is quite a
well link road with their aive two three
four
a43 sorry to the east which obviously
has good links into lamington and
Bambury as well so there's not seem to
be an issue from that and certainly
county highway 7 raised no objection on
traffic basis in terms of employee moves
it's it's a difficult one to say for
sure obviously there's always the
potential that the the perfect occupier
as it were could come in and use it has
the use of the site being compromised to
some extent by the residential well yes
it has so it's going to limit the amount
of people that could take it on and
certainly the market will be
significantly reduced in certainly in
terms of heavy industrial use will be
very limited on the site it has got
relatively good links but obviously it
is competing with a lot of other areas
Aetna lemming Tain's
Business Park and other ones in the
locality from what marketing certainly
the applicant has done and the evidence
that they've put forward we're satisfied
that you know that there's been
significant work and input and expert
advice to say that positive might may
eventually it's not guaranteed basically
and there's no definitive use for that
site as employment that could be
justified or there's no evidence to say
that there's there's someone lined up in
in
process they have done it for a certain
amount of time so whilst not being an
expert on it myself
officers are satisfied that enough
evidence has been gathered by the
applicant to show their case for having
it as residential rather than employment
in that case sir Perry Thank You chair I
just wonder that I could have some
clarification on our policy a s11 which
predominantly refers to large brownfield
sites can you just give some
clarification on numbers in terms of
because the large brown field sites that
are mentioned in the core strategy are
for significantly larger items had just
welcomed some the relevance on the large
brown Fayette fill sites as part of a
SRM
thank you three chair obviously there
are certain very specific strategic
sites law master and hobbies men works
the search that have been identified
directly through the policy in terms of
assessing other sites for their scale
this one is over five Hector's so it's
considered to be a large site for that
and it would be in combination with the
other site would be a hundred or
thereabout site so we have assessed this
site and other sites internally within
the site and basically the policy does
allow for other large brownfield sites
to come forward as you know the develop
will come forward in the core strategy
period and on this basis given their
previous history with the residential
land and how that was approved it was
felt that this additional twenty overall
as when you include the whole site with
the blue line as it's shown here would
fall under the classification as a large
rural brownfield site and to be honest
in terms of district wide the amount
that would have a similar sort of
criteria to this certainly being in this
case you know over five hectares I think
if you consider it in comparison to just
the village I think it would be
considered in that large scale and
certainly have anticipated spoken to
policy they read included up to site
within the assessment of that policy is
eleven in this respect so you making you
work hard tonight Eddie that cancer
field in speaker please Road the main
road there goes to Salim and then north
commentary not yeah you can't you can
nip through you can get to them soon put
yeah the
Road is forgets and become somewhere
thank you right any any further points
of clarification consoles a bite sorry
mr. Vance Thank You chair um I think
while star I do have sympathy with the
Parish Council and the ward member
because obviously if any Compton has
been subject to more than its fair share
I think on the evidence presented this
evening
we have in front of us a large brown
field site it's encouraging that the
agent has done a lot of engagement we'll
certainly tried to do enough engagement
with the Parish Council and the officer
has confirmed that this is part of the
brownfields right hopefully that will
mean that the houses if we if we were
are minded to grant this evening would
come through at a a reasonable level
that would attract families and that
young younger families as well
particularly if the housing mix is
adhered to strictly to our call strategy
so on that basis I'm happy to move to
propose to grant tax bonds personally
have an industrial next a residential
not always a good thing different sort
of traffic as well particularly with
lorries and that well as far as I'm
concerned because every young lady has
talked to the parents Council it's so
unfortunate not to aim and I'm happy to
secondly application for approval well
you can sponsor Chicago thank you I do
fully understand the desire of
communities to have some local
employment and it's not going to be
industrial it's going to be small scale
business startups and the why and this
is obviously a missed opportunity in
that particular respect
on the other side we do encourage the
use of brownfield sighs before we go on
to greenfield sites and certainly in
this context this is an ideal location
council bars have just said the exactly
where I was going to say as well the mix
of industrial and I think we should be
careful will use that word industrial it
really could be more business to start
up so they would be I mean there
wouldn't be necessarily extended hours
and such filing and it'll be just the
same as having for example the gym on
the site or business but I thought they
could have extended hours I think
reluctantly I will go along with council
Perry and council bars on this one I do
feel it is an opportunity that suddenly
has gone away and I mean they've gone
away it's not a viable site so on I will
I will go along with the the
recommendation my concern is that the
village of Fanny Compton has some very
narrow streets in the one-way system and
it is an access across to through a van
does it onto the Flemington Boundary
Road or the old lemming to Banbury Road
so there's quite a bottleneck that could
take place in that area however I do
agree that it is a brownfield site
there's gonna be certain amount of money
available to expand things like the
school or maybe also the doctor surgery
my colleagues Thank You chair um I'd
like to echo what my colleagues have
said especially echoing Rock term
councillor Cargill said it's a shame
that we're not boosting the rural
economy with this develop that
opportunity has passed and it's always
better to be looking at brownfields and
i'm greenfield and it's a thorough
application but you know just a
preoccupation they've looked at
connectivity for Wi-Fi and broadband and
things like that so they have tried to
engage so really i think it's a
well-thought-out application i'll be
going along with the obvious
recommendation yep we obviously have the
update sheet regarding from from county
council regarding their condition so I'm
sure we're all happy to accept those are
we and grant we decided whether to grant
a subject to those conditions under
section 106 so all those in favor
Thank You committee
resolves to grant application 18 / 0 1 2
0 9 780
subject to the 106 and the conditions
mentioned in the report and the object
sheet thank you
yo KJ right move on to the next item on
the agenda is application number 18 / 0
1 6 0 0 fu l9 Canton Road wild boar on
construction of one detached bungalow
with all associated works and it's a
presenting officer thank you Joe thank
you Jeff the application site sits on
the northern side of coins Road within a
built-up area boundary of Wales born the
site currently has one such training set
within the garden area there is also a
detached garage to the west of the
dwelling where the pros dwelling would
be site if approved the site has a
parking area set out to the front and a
good-sized rear garden further to West
beyond the existing guards of the
application site are two semi-detached
dwellings so the Easter site is a turret
detached right in and finally to the
north of the island are rare Gardens or
the property is on one for the close
this is an aerial shot of the site the
site is situated here this is the
dwelling this is the garage these are
two semi detached dwellings approved
across from the site is the library
this area is commercial where a number
of shops here is two shops as well which
is pharmacy this is the GP surgery and
as you can witness a number of dwellings
of very employers and architectural
styles a situation down the road of
Haram this is the existing solid plan
the garage is cited to the west which
can be seen here and the - and two-story
dwelling in this open parcel land was
approved in 2016 under application
reference 1602 to form SAS fall which is
within the officer's report the
application is seeking planning
permission for the erection of a one
bedroom bungalow
1/3 regimen
the existing garage would be demolished
and free parking spaces will be provided
to the front of the bungalow access will
be obtained from the existing engine
entrance point lead him from the
continent hold the bungalow is proposed
to have two front facing gables or a
free panel window to the west and a
single panel window to the east the
existing goes will be demolished and the
bungalow if approved will be set at five
point two meters in height to the rich
and five point eight meters wide on
13-point metres Inlet point five meters
and though the building remote would
remain and sits you to the existing
building line as seek move along the
street scene I was demonstrated on the
plan before you the bungalow is proposed
to have two bedrooms kitchen bathroom
and a rear-facing living room so the
living room here would be facing out
onto the garden area this is the
principal elevation for the bedroom and
the study this is holy street scene if
planning permission was forthcoming as
you can see the bungalow situated
between the two dwellings this is number
nine and this is number seven D
semi-detached well to the west this is
the approved one into the east and this
is already existing independent island
which is further beyond the site this is
the existing site area in the garage the
garage of the minute is set at four
point two meters were gable Ridge and
3.5 meters wide
this is existence east rain to the east
as you can see this is the garage
distance over the photo this is a semi
detached dwelling please take note the
defenestration
I'll go further and detail forever on
these are shots crossed from the road
and this is the pharmacy area further
down this is the angle to the west of
the site there's the garage two-story
dwelling the existing drain the approved
writing would be sat in that plot area
just there and that various forms
this is the one storey bungalow I've
referenced in the officer's report and
we were showing further on this is in
the gut existing garden area this is the
garage here and this is the existing
dwelling please take note that just
beyond this scene is where the window to
the kitchen area for 70 years which was
considered under appeal in 2016 and his
in detail when the officer report and
this is the rear when facing searches
doors out the rear of the garden this is
the existing bungalow which is a very
much similar design as proposed to
facing gables and you can just see the
garage is situated there unfortunately
was a button the way part but that's
where the bungalow situated circa about
50 metres away from the side this is a
primer ammok view taken of the shot
across from the road the close-up case
site is just there this is where the
approved one in 2016 would be cited for
inventory and this is the bungalow of
the similar designed just on the streets
in Austria commendations is for approval
subject to conditions are proposed
within within the committee report there
are no updates thank you thank you I
suppose he didn't actually get on to me
of the ran but thank you very much for
that we move on to our first speaker
which is catch the prior from whilst
born and Walton parish council
no cancer prior yeah three minutes as
usual and 30 seconds warning Bryn and
the Parish Council has come here to
object to this planning application the
previous application to have two extra
properties on the site was turned down
as appeal in relation to the development
between seventy and number nine the
counselor were at that time concerned
about the loss of amenity and light to
the adjacent property at seven D and the
overdevelopment of the site concerns
about over development have not
disappeared the proposed development has
an impact on the visual scene on count
and road there is only one of the
bungalow on this side of the road
leading out of the village and that was
also built within the garden of another
property and the numbers are 13 and 13 a
however that development has a
significantly larger plot and the
wide-angle lens is used on those
pictures do not indicate the actual size
of the plots that are in existence the
building in between in 13 and 13 a has
enough parking it has a driveway between
the house and the the bungalow has been
built along with the Mina tea space and
this is quite unlike the situation at
number nine and I do think as of suicide
that it would be a good idea for you to
visit it actually see what it looks like
and how small the plot is this proposed
development was being no closer to 17
and the garage currently situated there
extends beyond the rear building line of
7d creating an overhang on that building
whilst we agree that the building would
not have a significant impact on the
light into the living room of 7d it will
still have a significant impact as
currently there is a large clear space
between the rear building line of 7d and
number nine
Council is concerned about the parking
on the proposed development there are
three spaces provided in front of the
bungalow one for the proposed
development one for number nine and one
visitor space the submission then states
that there are three further tandem
spaces available
this however is not entirely accurate
planning permission has already been
granted for a two-story house to be
built to the right of number nine an
application which by the way the parish
council supported the access to this
would remove those three tandem spaces
in effect then the proposal provides
three spaces for a two-bedroom bungalow
and a three-bedroom house this is
clearly not in accordance with planning
requirements the proposed parking works
only if number nine and the proposed
bungalow are occupied by the family as
stated in some of the documentation
thirty Seconds planning decisions are
not made on this basis is not a planning
reason to say that the bungalow is for a
family member and therefore that the
parking provision is sufficient the
applicant has made it very clear that
the proposed development is not an
ancillary building to number nine it's
an independent development we would ask
that you reject this application on
those grounds
thank you you can't surprise spot-on as
usual any questions for the post-cancer
building the last image and Kami's zoom
in to show exactly where this all it is
and the way it's the bungalow existing
bungler okay because it does very much
appear that there's John
you can ask it's probably better for
points of clarification I thought you're
gonna come back and ask answer prior
question you've got a question please
sure good evening um how has the
applicant responded to posh councils
concerns what level of engagement has
the beam I'm only aware of any
engagement over this application I have
to say that when this application came
to council I was actually on holiday so
I've come to represent Council I'm not
certain whether they were there that
meeting but we certainly haven't heard
anything else come from the applicants
questions free to go can't surprise mr.
Page or mr. face there for questions and
not presented that's all right we've got
there sorry about that
that was a technical forward on my
behalf Bishop with 30 seconds if that's
okay you've got three minutes
[Music]
circumstances have changed while Mike
recovered from a quadruple heart bypass
my mum was faced with months of
chemotherapy she's doing well and he's
still active or their reliance on my
father to drive her to medical
appointments and for heavier household
chores supporting them is key so we have
to consider how we can best help
than here on this proposed one-stroke
two-bedroom bungalow is designed to
support their future needs providing
them with independent living right next
door this would reduce their reliance on
social services giving us all more peace
of mind so they can enjoy more worryfree
family and social time we have engaged
with our neighbors at 7 D listen to
concerns and have addressed the issues
raised by the appeals inspector to
minimize potential impact on 7 D there
is no overshadowing overlooking
overbearing impact with only minimal
reduction of direct sunlight and no loss
of view to the sky from their side
ground floor window the appeals
inspector has already recognized that
the plot is entirely capable of
accommodating and sustaining a single
dwelling
it would also align with the recently
approved parish neighborhood plan that
advocates a vote for bungalows the plot
currently houses a dilapidated garage
this photograph here shows from left to
right the two semis of 7 C and D are
hedge and detached garage there is very
little difference between the current
Street View and the proposed what we
proposed due to the high hedges the
picture the proposed bungalow roof been
the same as the existing garage it is
the same distance from 7 D as the garage
the height is just one meter higher than
the current garage as well and the
retention of a 2.2 meter gap between the
bungalow proposed bungalow and number 9
the appeals inspector also recognized
it's difficult to identify identify
sameness along 32nd its charm and
character coming from the diversity of
styles sizes and positioning and with
the proposed Street View not dissimilar
to what already exists there's no need
for the street view to be compromised
it is indeed enhanced by the
all of the dilapidated garage of
wasteland through the reuse of suitable
London property within the built-up area
of Wales born the bungalow would offer
longer-term benefits to Wales born for
the able-bodied or otherwise single
person or couple and may well become
part of our own retirement spot-on thank
you any questions okay I see there's a
couple of letters of objection do you
know have you spoken to the neighbor if
you disable two meters away from
Esteban's I know in the presentation the
applicant did save I've spoken to the
yeah thank you very much sure free to go
well not too far be banished sent to
detention took him bed detention we can
we have our warden under police catch
the parry
she'll be putting me in detention later
good evening everybody
um first of all I'm disappointed that my
request for a site visit made on 1st
November was not actioned until 12th
November giving too short notice prior
to this meeting for myself and other
members to attend a site visit this
afternoon at 4:00 p.m. and for this
reason I would ask that this application
is deferred to enable this to happen
with the appropriate notice secondly I'd
like to say that I'm not against infill
development on the Kyneton Road in Wales
born providing it is appropriate and
blends in with the character of other
neighboring properties it is for this
reason that I supported the application
to the right of the host dwelling which
has been designed to complement the
three-story properties to its left
intrinsic to my assessment is
the fact that the site is not capable of
accommodating a single dwelling and such
regions have been used previously by
planning officers of SDC in Mountford
close wells born and that was before we
had the call strategy approved the flat
is clear to see in here I've taken two
pictures took them actually on Monday
morning with my iPhone so not a fancy
camera just straight with the iPhone to
give you the example of the difference
between the this particular application
which you see on your left and you see
the distance between the two houses and
the the other one is the distance this
is for the 13 a which is in Clinton Road
which is literally two two houses up
kind and Road and the parish council
joins in with me feeling that the site
of where the garage is it's like a
sandwich but it's like the meat between
the sandwich and would extend way beyond
the existing garage so squeezing this
application onto the appeal site
dismissed by the planning inspector
means that this is a clear case of
overdevelopment bearing in mind we've
given permission for that for
development on the right hand side it is
significantly smaller in plot size and
these proposals would destroy the
setting of properties either side of it
bearing in mind it is basically in the
center of the village street scene
because we've got shops etc just down
there so it is the key part of wells
born in my view such development would
result in a cramped built form be shoved
in that space and consequently it fails
to comply with policy cs9 the proposal
would therefore have negative effect on
the light on the neighboring property
entering the kitchen and living room by
blocking the window the window faces
southeast where the majority of sunlight
enters this main living space this would
affect the amenity of the occupiers and
course material harm because the
proposal is a single storey building
located immediately neck
to a three-story house this would cause
further issues regarding unacceptable
levels of foul smells you saw on the
plan that the bathroom is right and
basically opposite the kitchen window
the neighboring property how can it be
right for a neighboring bathroom and
toilet with its waste system so close to
a kitchen and living space has Building
Control looked at these plans for
disposal of waste and foul drainage I
therefore wish to remind members about
cs9 proposals including layout and
orientation will be sensitive to the
setting existing built form neighboring
uses etc occupants of neighboring
buildings will be protected from
unacceptable levels of noise
contamination and pollution as well as
the loss of daylight and privacy the
design of this bungalow simply does not
fit the street scene because of its
crammed in space it is inappropriate due
to the plot having insufficient space
the proposal is made to materially no
different to that dismissed by the
inspector in 2017 although a bungalow
has been built at 13 a kind and Road
just two properties up the road and you
can show the next side Jo the plot sizes
are not in any way comparable with 13a
being situated on a much larger
appropriate sized plot at the end of the
day you know I think we've got enough
information to refuse this it's over
development also with the updated MPP F
paragraph 47 it clearly states that
Planning law requires the application
for planning permission be determined in
accordance with our policies cs9 I
understand there's also a restrictive
covenant on the whole area of nine sorry
it's okay thank you very much please
either defer or refuse thank you before
we go to questions for the ward member
I'll just make sure we're clear what
we're going to do next you miss
first of all our beer skin catch the
Perry just to reiterate the reasons for
deferral I will then be asking for
questions to the ward member we will
then be having the points of
clarification and when we come to the
debate we will then go to the proposal
for a deferral so if everybody's clear
well that
have we been on this side busy yeah no
there's been no site visit it was so I
mean for the chrome so can you just
clarify I couldn't hear what you said
there was a site visit in respect to the
appeal yeah but not for this questions
okay so dunno am I allowed to ask counts
Lipari to complete what she was just
about to say when her time run out about
the stricter covenant you can ask for
more information about the Covenant but
you can't ask her to employ what she was
going to say restrictive covenants are
property laws are not planning law so
it's not relevant I'm afraid sorry
so yeah we'll we'll be going through the
points of clarification and then we'll
be debating whether we defer thank you
care Safari right the bonds well I think
the pictures we've had it been good
enough but I think I know that road so I
think that the knowledge I've got maybe
not others yeah I know this routine
which is what the important in factories
just cargo just one please Joe regard
parking spaces does that meet our
current standards thank you sir
under the assessment the Highways
Authority did originally a jet and then
the applicant submitted new information
under their assessment and this is under
our open market assessment because I
know which Caesar enraged over the
family thing
according to always forty on ourselves
it does meet its requirements and there
is no severe impact on the highways
Network and the question was have we got
enough parking spaces to our yeah
because a bungalow situated things so
you've got the three spaces so it's on
the screen now so you've got the three
spaces we situated for there you've got
a warm space proposed there and of
course they got three space to trust
their survival was over seven spaces
post this is only for a bungalow as well
these free story but doing so in lower
part requirements submission shared
access drive idiots yes points
right okay it's the car go thank you
I've got some real concerns about this
particular application
I would I would definitely recommend
that we go and have a look on this to
the on the site and to see the concerns
that the counter Paris and the council
have presented on this one because I
really have got some concerns about this
government men that I don't have to
proposing we've just to say what your
what your concerns are that we need to
buy or me looking at these first of all
I obviously obviously you mentioned
about the shared access and parking
right this the architectural style I'm
not convinced about if in character with
the with the area I know the applicants
put forward that there is an existing in
fact that the officer is well the
existing bungalow but I would suggest
that of questionable design in that
particular context to and it shouldn't
be used as a reference for granting
although the property proposed property
is behind the hedge it still will be
from there and hedges can be removed and
so I want to make sure that we are aware
of that one and again that would then
affect the street scene I believe it is
overdevelopment to the site I think is
to to squeeze in on there and although
the applicants have presented their
personal reasons for this development
this committee can't grant a permission
on that basis only we must of course
because of course conditions can change
and then it could be come back onto the
onto the open market so it has to stand
alone as a good planning application in
that particular context I am not
convinced Thank You chair am i echoing I
think actually councillor cargoes just
says thank you mark you've summed it up
beautifully and it is unfortunate that
we can't really take personal
circumstances into consideration because
it must be strictly planning reasons and
I fully on the Phi's with the picture
that was painted regarding their current
situation I think one award member asked
for a site visit to the extent that
counts the parry has there must be a
very very good reason in it it's really
getting much fairer on view for both
applicant and committee if if we go and
do a site visit I think because there's
a number of concerns especially over
development to the site and the cs9 is
my concern thank you very much that so
we've had a proposal from against the
cargo to defer on a second by cancer
tunnel to fix our concerns about the
shared access over development effects
on seats street scene sorry and cs9
policy cs9 should we go about all those
in favor for deferral committee resolves
to refer okay refer sorry defer
application 18 / 0 1 6 0 0 a few hours
the purpose of this job so we can
necessitate eight site visit thank you
delegation right yeah
a brief adjournment I see there's no
speech back I see there's no speakers on
this can we go straight to we'll just
going to come on to that one thank you
can't stop our how I'm glad you've got
your drink and refreshed no not a
problem
we want our next application which is
number 18 / 0 to 1 to 0 Ethan's coming
to red arms get prepare a single story
double garage and it's part of the
Constitution as though no speakers and
no ward members we've got the option to
dedicate this application to officers to
the barn second bike at Safari that we
dedicate this decision committing
resolves to dedicate the decision for
this application to officers in lima
constitution
anything any other business there no
urgent business but catch spies before
you go we there is something that
doesn't write to this meeting but I'd
like you to stay behind
please so I will